Hey, so I have something interesting for you
guys right now, because it is yet more Trump
flunky gaslighting on corporate media.
But it's also a super important kind of critical
thinking and epistemology concept.
And it goes to the question of the Mayo brand.
Mark Meadows didn't think he was going to
be instructive.
But how do we know things?
We do observation.
We sometimes generalize.
We look to authorities.
We apply research methods, the scientific
method.
It's a very big conversation.
But when we're dealing with empirical questions
that you're not testing in a sort of double-blind
format, we need to apply some other concepts
which we are going to discuss shortly.
And this leads us to Donald Trump's chief
of staff, Mark Meadows, who went on CNN and
talked about the supposed voter fraud, a vote
by mail that Trump is going to be pushing
to suppress vote by mail this election.
And Jake Tapper from CNN points out there's
no evidence of widespread voter fraud when
people vote by mail.
And Mark Meadows says, well, there's no evidence
that there isn't widespread voter fraud.
Take a look at this.
Sending ballots out just just based on a voter
roll registration.
Any time you move, you'll change your driver's
license.
But don't call up and say, oh, wait lines.
Voter fraud, though, that there's no evidence
of widespread voter fraud.
There's no there's no evidence that there's
not either.
That's the definition of fraud, Jake.
When we look at that, what we have seen are
a number about mail.
So this is really instructive.
Like, not not only does Mark Meadows skull
seem to be filled with mayonnaise here or
vegan EHS, if that's your your preference.
This leads us to Ockham's Razor.
Ockham's Razor is a concept which we often
interpret or simplify, as if you have competing
explanations for something.
We should prefer the simpler explanation in
the sense that it requires the fewest assumptions
and fewest secondary explanations of either
unknown or invisible phenomena.
So I'll give you some examples if I say that
car seems to be running.
I hear it running in the tachometer says a
thousand R.P.M..
I am.
I believe the car has gasoline in it.
Assuming it's not an electric car.
Right.
You could come out and say, you don't know
that, David.
The car could be out of gas, but you're hearing
a speaker pumping out noise that sounds like
an engine that's running.
And the tachometer might have been manipulated
to show a thousand even when the car isn't
really on.
OK.
I mean, I guess that's possible, but it's
implausible.
And the first explanation, which is when you
see a car, you hear the noise of the car running
and the tachometer shows a thousand.
The car probably has gas.
It requires fewer assumptions.
And the person suggesting the wacky hypothesis
should have to provide evidence that they
are right.
You could say, David, you don't have proof
that my theory is false.
But intuitively, we know that that's the person
that should be proving to us that we should
consider their hypothesis.
Another example, if I say, look, it's an empty
room.
You could say there could be an invisible
tiger in here.
And I'd say, well, if there was an invisible
tiger in here, we would still hear the tiger.
The tiger might smell.
We might see the tiger moving around dust
as it walks around.
And you could say now, now the tiger is invisible.
But it's also odorless and weightless and
silent.
It doesn't make any noise.
And you don't have proof that that's not going
on.
I think you get the idea.
These are indefeasible arguments.
You can't defeat them because they will always
say, well, you haven't proved otherwise definitively.
Jake Tapper, of course, should have said you're
asserting some something for which there is
no evidence.
So the onus is on you to prove it, simply
saying it hasn't been proven that there isn't
voter fraud is not actually sufficient.
Now, it gets even crazier.
During this interview here, Mark Meadows claims
that despite numerous reports, no voting machines
have been taken off line.
But if they were taken off line, it's definitely
Barack Obama's fault.
Are you saying that sorting machines have
not been taken off line and removed?
Are you a certain.
I'm not.
I'm saying that short shorting machines between
now and the election will not be taken off
line.
Listen, I had postal undermined the ones that
had taken off line.
No.
But listen, here's what I'm saying is when
you look at it, the normal process of doing
all of this, Jake.
I had the postal system under I had the only
bipartisan bill to actually deal with one
hundred and forty six billion dollar loss
that the Postal Service has been will see
over the next ten years.
And so when you're looking at this, these
postal machines and the the drawdown, that
was a 2006 bill that has been implemented
that I don't necessarily agree with.
But that's not this postmaster general that
that they did that that was the previous postmaster
general under Obama.
So if you're struggling to understand that
you aren't alone, do not adjust your brain.
It's actually incoherent.
Voting machines haven't been taken off line.
But there was a bill under Obama to do it.
But it hasn't happened this time.
But it did happen, but not now.
So if it's because of that bill that you see
it, then blame Obama.
What then?
Jake Tapper provides evidence that actually
voting machines are being taken off line.
And Mark Meadows says, oh, it's all normal
and nothing to be alarmed about.
But remember, he said minutes earlier that
it wasn't happening at all in terms of the
fact check that you asked me to look into.
Yeah, my great producers did in terms of the
machines.
Chris Brett Bentley, president of the National
Postal Mail Handlers Union, local to ninety
seven, which covers Kansas and parties agree
to go to the Trump.
States, told CNN that postal management has
already taken out four machines in Kansas
City, two machines in Springfield, Missouri,
and one machine in Wichita, Kansas.
That is earlier this year under this new postmaster
general.
No, no, no.
With all due respect, and if we look at it,
I can talk to Kansas.
I can talk to Tucson, Arizona.
You're talking to someone who knows is when
we take out those processing, they're part
of a processing center that come comes in
and as we start to move those out.
If they were not part of an already scheduled
reallocation, it's not happening.
It's not a new initiative by this postmaster
general.
And when we look at this, it's all about efficiency.
But you have a normal system of changing it
out.
And so with with all due respect of your fact
checker, I'll be glad to come in.
We can spend an hour talking about this will
bore people to death.
But I can tell you this, the post office has
been losing money for over 10 years.
OK.
So the full explanation is this isn't happening.
If it is, it's Barack Obama's fault, not the
current postmaster general.
But since it is happening, it's actually not
happening now.
Oh, well, no, but it is.
But it was the previous postmaster general
whose influence is actually what's responsible
here.
And any way we should treat the post office
like a business instead of the public service
that it is.
This is Trump's chief of staff.
This is not some random congressman anymore.
He was some random congressman.
Now, this is Donald Trump's chief of staff.
We're in real trouble heading into this election